marcando El Aniversario número 25 del
acuerdo del viernes santo Para el cual
la participación de Washington fue clave
el presidente de Estados Unidos Joe
biden celebró su importancia en belfast
También aprovecho para pedir la
restauración del gobierno
descentralizado de Irlanda del Norte que
colapsó hace más de un año después de
que el partido unionista democrático lo
boicoteare descontento por los acuerdos
posteriores al brexit
como amigo Espero que no sea demasiado
presuntuoso decir que creo que las
instituciones democráticas establecidas
a través del acuerdo del viernes Santo
siguen siendo fundamentales para el
futuro de Irlanda espero que pronto se
restablezca la asamblea y El Ejecutivo
el presidente de Estados Unidos elogió
El reciente acuerdo del marco de Windsor
que tiene como objetivo aliviar las
barreras comerciales posteriores al
brexit entre Irlanda del Norte y el
resto del Reino Unido también se reunió
brevemente con el Primer Ministro
británico Richie sunak quien dijo que
las relaciones entre su país y los
Estados Unidos pasan por un muy buen
momento a pesar de las críticas de las
figuras unionistas sobre la asociación
hablamos sobre el potencial de inversión
y las empresas que quieren invertir en
Irlanda del norte creo que es
increíblemente emocionante traerá
empleos conocimiento y prosperidad a
Irlanda del Norte pero este también es
un viaje sentimental para biden el
presidente cruzó la frontera más tarde
el miércoles hacia el condado de loud De
donde son sus antepasados y visitó el
castillo de carlington
Ojalá nuestra madre
estuviera aquí hoy laud ocupa un lugar
tan especial en su corazón
y venir aquí siempre se siente como
volver a casa biden permanecerá en la
República de Irlanda hasta el final de
su viaje donde se reunirá con el
presidente de Irlanda Michael higgins